[Musique]
vous reconnaissez ce geste
ah peut-être peut-être qu'en ce moment
il y en a qui sont en train de le faire
dans la salle
ça s'appelle le scrolling de scrolling
on parle même aujourd'hui de scrolling
infini pour justement désigner cette
pratique qui consiste comme ça à
scroller pendant une heure sur Instagram
par exemple avec des vidéos qui se
lancent automatiquement sans avoir même
une seule fois cliqué
les Anglo-Saxons parlent de dooms
crawling dooms crawling pour dire en
fait si on prend dans le sens littéral
du terme dooms scrolling ça signifie
défilement morbide morbide
[Musique]
c'est pas très rassurant
et c'est vrai qu'on peut ne pas être
très rassuré quand on sait qu'on passe
en moyenne trois heures trente juste sur
les applications mobiles par jour ça
fait quand même beaucoup
ça fait beaucoup alors on parle
aujourd'hui d'hyper connexion
on parle de cyberdépendance c'est un
terme qui émerge on parle de crétin
digital
vous avez l'impression
digital je ne sais pas
bon sérieusement c'est vrai que
actuellement les neurosciences
s'intéressent de près au sujet et
comment ça faire le lien entre cette
dépendance là si elle existe et
peut-être celle qu'on a notamment dans
les jeux d'argent
donc ça nous rassure ça nous rassure pas
beaucoup et en particulier quand on est
parent
parce que nos enfants sont les premières
personnes connectées aujourd'hui et si
nous on est vulnérables alors eux n'en
parlons pas
donc dans certaines familles
des gros questionnements arrivent moi
par exemple ma fille rentre au collège
l'année prochaine et ça y est la
question du téléphone est d'arriver et
je ne sais pas je sais pas à quoi lui
répondre
on n'a pas les solutions aujourd'hui en
tant que parents
dans certaines familles même ça va plus
loin c'est carrément une guerre des
écrans
mais comment lutter
en tant que parents comment lutter
quand la moitié des élèves de 6e possède
un téléphone portable
comment lutter quand toutes les
conversations des ados tournent autour
de TikTok de snapchat de YouTube
comment lutter comment lutter contre
nous-même on est tout le temps connecté
alors voilà on s'acharne à lutter contre
les écrans
mais moi ce qui m'interpelle c'est qu'on
parle beaucoup des écrans
mais l'écran en lui-même ça veut pas
dire grand chose
alors peut-être qu'on parle de l'écran
parce que ça matérialise notre connexion
ça lui donne corps ça lui donne vie ça
rend palpable l'impalpable ça rend réel
tout ce qui est virtuel aujourd'hui
mais derrière l'écran il y a en fait une
multitude de pratiques numériques
différentes
on fait tous et toutes des choses très
très différentes sur les réseaux sociaux
sur Internet
et puis on a des pratiques évolutives on
fait pas la même chose moi par exemple
je faisais pas la même chose il y a 5
ans qu'aujourd'hui sur Internet
et puis surtout il y a une pratique
qui me paraît intéressante quand même
sur Internet c'est les recherches on
fait beaucoup de recherches et en fait
on a accès à un savoir mais c'est
vraiment inédit ça on a oublié on a
oublié que quand on était à un ado de 12
ans dans les années 90 on n'avait pas
accès à ce savoir si nos parents avaient
pas les moyens financer d'acheter une
encyclopédie universaliste qui prenait
toute la place du salon on pouvait pas
aujourd'hui on a accès à ce savoir pour
quelques euros par mois
c'est quand même incroyable
internet c'est quand même une belle
histoire au départ
c'est le World Wide Web les trois W
c'est cette démocratisation du savoir
c'est aussi une belle histoire de
militantisme comment ne pas penser à
Mitou qui est quand même la troisième
révolution féministe en Occident comment
ne pas penser à yucca une application
qui a révolutionné nos usages et qui a
rendu qui a rendu possible à
consommation engagée et ça ça a été
possible parce que yucca en fait a
bénéficié de toutes ces données libres
d'accès qui existent sur une plateforme
qui s'appelle open food fact c'est des
citoyens des citoyennes qui récoltent
ces données sur les produits et qui les
partagent à une communauté c'est fou
mais c'est vrai que cette liberté
fondatrice d'Internet il faut bien
l'avouer qu'on a un peu perdu ces
dernières années
on a un peu perdu parce que internet
c'est ce grand espace d'un seul coup
cette ouverture comme ça rendu possible
et bien il y a des petites entreprises
qu'on appelle des start-up
petite quelques petites entreprises qui
ont vu cette espèce s'ouvrir à eux
à elle
et qu'ils ont accaparé
et ces petites entreprises sont devenues
en quelques années ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui les big tech les gafam si
vous voulez
et ces entreprises elles ont leur propre
vision américaine libertarienne
et puis
ces entreprises il faut bien le
constater elles font pas preuve de
beaucoup de diversité au sein de leurs
équipes
en fait aujourd'hui le secteur de la
tech il est à majorité composé d'hommes
blancs issus d'école de commerce et
d'ingénieurs
issus des classes aisées
il y a un chiffre qui fâche dans le
secteur c'est 10%
10% en France des startups sont créées
par des femmes et seulement 1% d'entre
elles lèvent des fonds
des grandes startups aujourd'hui qui
sont portés par des femmes
10% des développeurs sont des
développeuses également qui en fait très
peu de femmes qui conçoivent les outils
qu'on utilise aujourd'hui
quotidiennement tout le temps et ça
c'est problématique
il y a des speakers qui parlent beaucoup
des biais des billets cognitifs qu'on a
en fait et bien dans le secteur le
problème c'est que les biais cognitifs
se retrouvent dans les produits qu'on
utilise
et on se retrouve avec des outils des
technologies qu'on dit discriminants par
exemple amazon a développé comme ça un
algorithme de recrutement qui ne faisait
pas remonter les profils de femmes
ça c'est quand même une grosse
problématique il y en a une autre
il y en a une autre
c'est le modèle économique de ces
entreprises
alors encore un petit peu d'histoire
Internet est né il y a 20 ans donc à une
époque de la gratuité tout était gratuit
les blogs les forums et donc ils se sont
elles se sont développées ces
entreprises dans cet espace de gratuité
mais on le sait une entreprise ne
fonctionne pas gratuitement c'est pas
possible donc elles ont trouvé un modèle
économique qu'on appelle le l'économie
de l'attention
de plus en plus parler
l'économie de l'attention en fait
qu'est-ce qu'on vend on vend votre temps
votre temps de cerveau disponible on
connaît l'histoire donc notre temps
c'est un espace publicitaire pour des
annonceurs qui veulent annoncer sur
Facebook Instagram Twitter et compagnie
et ces entreprises elles ont fait ça
bien
elles se sont fait accompagner par des
experts en neurosciences elles ont fait
ce qu'on appelle du neuromarketing c'est
à dire qu'elles ont étudié comme un
autre cerveau fonctionnel
pour faire des produits qui font que
effectivement on a envie d'y revenir
tout le temps le scrolling le fameux
scrolling c'est exactement la même
mécanique que les machines à sous
les notifications on sait qu'aujourd'hui
quand on reçoit une notification il y a
une sécrétion de dopamine cette hormone
du plaisir qui fait qu'on a envie de
recevoir tout le temps et donc d'être
tout le temps connecté
alors voilà pour en revenir à nos écrans
nos maudits moi je me demande est-ce
qu'il faut vraiment se méfier des écrans
est-ce que c'est vraiment eux le
problème
le problème est-ce que c'est pas plutôt
quelques entreprises
est-ce que c'est pas plutôt certains
algorithmes certaines applications
le problème aussi c'est qu'on nous a pas
appris à nous méfier on a vu la magie
magie de la technologie on connaît cette
expression et on sait pas rendu compte
qu'une simple connexion à les
transformer absolument tous nos modes de
vie
alors ça c'est quelque chose qui à un
moment donné dans mon histoire
professionnelle m'a frappé et qui m'a
donné envie de créer un magazine ce
magazine papier
avec mes associés qui parlent des
grandes mutations liées aux technologies
au numérique mais aujourd'hui on se rend
compte
que c'est pas suffisant
il suffit pas d'informer il faut se
former il faut former
donc soyons réalistes soyons
pragmatiques les écrans on va pas
décider comme ça de vivre sans du jour
au lendemain ils font partie de nos vies
on va pas lutter contre les écrans sans
les écrans
donc si combat il doit y avoir ce combat
il doit se faire autrement
et moi je suis convaincue que ce combat
il doit se faire par l'éducation dans
les écoles
ce qui est absolument génial aujourd'hui
c'est qu'il y a de plus en plus
d'initiatives des associations qui se
mobilisent justement sur ce sujet je
peux vous citer fréquenté l'école le
Clémi les interviennent ces associations
dans dans les écoles donc pour donner
des ateliers d'éducation aux médias donc
aider les jeunes à mieux apprendre
comment se servir d'Internet nous aussi
on veut lancer un nouveau magazine pour
les ados justement mais encore une fois
c'est pas suffisant
on en est convaincu aujourd'hui ce qu'il
faudrait c'est des cours d'éducation
civique et numérique dans absolument
tous les collèges
alors qu'est-ce qu'on apprendrait dans
cette école du numérique
et bien le Béa bas on apprendrait à
faire des recherches maintenant que le
savoir est absolument partout
le but du jeu c'est d'apprendre à trier
cette information apprendre même à la
sourcer comme disent les journalistes on
devrait tous apprendre quelques
techniques journalistiques de base
savoir sourcer l'information savoir ce
que c'est qu'un clickbait vous savez ce
que c'est qu'un clic date un clicvate
c'est un titre hameçon un titre vous
avez envie de cliquer c'est un clic
piège voilà
et en fait derrière il y a très souvent
assez souvent des contenus complotistes
par exemple
ils utilisent en tout cas beaucoup cette
mécanique ça serait vraiment intéressant
que les jeunes apprennent ça
qu'est-ce qu'on apprendrait d'autre dans
cette école du numérique
peut-être qu'on apprendrait à se
déconnecter à faire des pauses
et peut-être que même nous les adultes
on aimerait bien suivre ses cours de
temps en temps
bon vous allez me dire c'est peut-être
pas évident d'apprendre à se déconnecter
justement quand on sait qu'il y a tous
ce modèle économique de l'attention qui
nous capte en permanence comment on fait
comment on peut faire et ben justement
ça aussi il faut la prendre il faut la
prendre ce que c'est que le modèle
économique de la tension
les ados passent énormément de temps sur
les réseaux sociaux nous aussi on doit
savoir comment il fonctionne
et qu'est-ce qu'on ferait après une fois
qu'on serait tout ça et bien peut-être
que nous aussi on aura envie de mettre
notre grain de sel peut-être que nous
aussi on aura envie de créer des outils
numériques avec d'autres modèles
économiques que celui de la tension par
exemple des outils moins discriminants
des outils qui soient plus respectueux
de la vie privée de nos données par
exemple
peut-être qu'on pourrait comme ça
prendre le pouvoir au sens anglo-saxon
du terme on dit M power vraiment c'est
ça se donner le pouvoir et transformer
comme ça la société
alors voilà ce que j'avais envie de dire
ce soir c'est juste un message que
j'aimerais faire passer c'est celui-ci
ne laissons pas ne laissons plus
quelques-uns nous dicter les règles
numériques et prenons le pouvoir sur les
technologies c'est peut-être comme ça
qu'on arrivera à pas devenir des crétins
digitaux
[Applaudissements]